let's talk a little bit about celebrity
endorsements as you know the this has
become something of importance
apparently especially for one political
party that uh likes to try to get all
these so-called celebrities to come out
and endorse them of course I'm talking
primarily about the Democratic party and
Comm Harris and what we had to deal with
and hear and see and um I think all of
us in instinctively understand how it's
silly and stupid but I'd like to take a
moment and kind of break it down and
show you how this is actually very very
dangerous um in three ways in the first
way the most evident way which you
probably understand is who are these
people that we're supposed to care about
all right I mean I I don't want to pick
on him but Robert DeNiro who I liked as
an actor I enjoy his movies and so forth
and then of course you ruined it by
exposing him himself as you know some
guy suffering from Trump derangement
syndrome or whatever it is um but he's
just one of many right um and they all
come out screaming and a lot of them of
course come out for came out for Kam
Harris etc etc and the first point is
like who cares who are you people what
are your credentials it's one thing to
say you know here's a news analyst who's
got a PhD from Harvard and in politics
and you know he's got experience uh you
know he understand he's a PO pollster
and he's right all right I get that but
you people celebrities why on Earth does
anyone care who you are what you have to
say and that's what I just said I'm sure
you already have thought that all right
and there's nothing new here but let me
give you a fun fact that really
underscores what I'm saying so as you
know uh our the English language a lot
of it is derived from Latin and Greek um
and there's a our word hypocrite is a
Greek word it comes uh from the
classical ancient Greeks you know BC
times uh and it's pronounced hakra or
Hypocrites right it's a noun and guess
what it means let me show you here's my
book uh here's my little Greek Lexicon
which I got uh back in the 90s when I
was studying Greek uh with Victor Davis
Hansen by the way fun times let me read
to you what a hypocrates
is a hypocrates is one who plays a part
on the stage a player an actor all right
so our word hypocrite and you know what
that means of course it's a two-faced
liar to the Greeks really meant an actor
and isn't that perfect doesn't that
totally encapsulate what an actor is
think about it what is the claim to fame
of an actor he he can pretend to be what
he's not and get you to believe in it
okay I can't do that I'm not a good
actor you're probably not either we have
too much dignity these people are so
good at their fraud they're so good at
pretending to be what they're not okay
uh on on the screens or whatever that
they convince you okay there you know
and so when it's all said and done
they're so good at lying okay and these
are the people that we and or some
people are uh listening to we're taking
their advice and you know the I mean the
word hypocrite which is what an actor is
like I told you from the Greek it's even
it's it's so obvious I mean look at them
these are the same people who will tell
you about the climate and the
environment and then they will pollute
the environment with their private jets
that is a quintessential hypocrite and
that is the meaning of the word
hypocrite actor that's who they are so
that's the first part the second problem
which is even worse is that people fall
for this people are that dumb okay
that's pretty sad in this country
there's a lot of stupid people okay the
fact that I understand why actors do
what they do they probably get paid
money too I don't even a lot of these
actors who came out let's say for KLA
Harris they probably don't even care one
way or the other but they got paid and
that's all that's their agent told them
here I got a gig for you say these words
and we'll pay you and they did it
because they're Hypocrites they're they
actors they're Pretenders okay the sad
part is that there's actually a
percentage of people in this country who
fall for that who actually go around
voting based on my favorite actor told
me to I mean that is dumb people all
right that is much worse than the first
point the third point is that nobody
seems to care this is like an accepted
wonderful aspect of the political
landscape nobody's saying hey this is a
real it and we need to fix it we need to
deal with it everyone is saying this is
a reality how can we manipulate it for
our party openly and I'll just read to
you one quote uh from a well-known
famous
pollster let me pull it up here
uh okay so two weeks before the El or
maybe 10 days before the election uh the
well-known poster Frank Lun breathlessly
said on CNN I have the video quote so
what I'm waiting to see is whether
Taylor Swift comes out and does a
concert to endorse KL Harris I think
that is a big deal he said she is as
popular today as Oprah Winfrey was when
she endorsed Barack Obama and Oprah
support active support made a difference
in his race Taylor Swift could make a
difference in this race so that's
disgusting I mean the fact alone is
disgusting but the fact that a guy who's
on CNN is sort sort of boasting about it
as as a as something that you know hey
let's try to manipulate and harness the
power of this is even more problematic
because it suggests that hey we it's
cool we accept it this is normal let's
do this sort of thing and yet I mean at
the same time we get these people
telling us hey we need to preserve
democracy what kind of democracy is this
where a a chunk of the people are
imbeciles who are being led by
Hypocrites and we all understand and
agree to that and endorse it and openly
try to see who can manipulate and
exploit it the most for their game what
a joke all right so um I'm glad to see
where the election went this year but
you know what what KLA Harris did get
probably a lot more votes just because
of the so-called celebrity endorsements
all right um and we don't know what's
going to happen in the future maybe
these celebrity endorsements in as much
as Americans become stupider than they
already are will become even a greater
Factor so at some point they may be so
decisive that your president and your
policies are based on a bunch of
Hypocrites both linguistically and
realistically bye